jardin passion jardin détente lors de
cette troisième édition du salon art et
jardin à la Bergerie Nationale de
Rambouillet ce samedi 8 avril
professionnel de l'aménagement et
artisan d'art s'était donné rendez-vous
pour présenter les dernières tendances
de mobilier extérieur pergola chaise
colorée ou hamac un lieu de vie majeur
dans le cœur des Français avec le retour
des beaux jours et la pièce principale
de ma maison
faut que ce soit joli c'est comme à la
maison la décoration c'est important
depuis la crise du covid-19 cette
professionnelle remarque un regain
d'intérêt pour l'aménagement extérieur
du jardin elle propose du mobilier sur
mesure avec du bois résineux résistant
aux intempéries le pince et le matériau
qu'on va décliner sous toutes ses formes
c'est-à-dire pour la terrasse la pergola
de la bride des carports c'est le
matériau qu'on va retrouver le plus chez
nous donc il est traité traité autoclave
il est fait pour être en extérieur cet
artisan crée des décorations en verre
pour le jardin elle note l'importance du
public pour la personnalisation de cet
espace chez moi j'ai l'impression c'est
vraiment le coup de cœur
qu'ils accrochent et puis que les
interpellent et pour se faire plaisir et
qui donne le petit côté rigolo à leur
jardin ce sont des polos qui ressemblent
beaucoup aux Shadok mais c'est pas des
Shadows on peut les accrocher à
l'intérieur ou à l'extérieur et les pics
de jardin pareil c'est la technique du
fusil de verre ça c'est la technique
Tiffany du vitrail dans le jardin des
Français les cernes sont plus simplement
utilisés pour cultiver depuis quelques
années cette entreprise réalise 50% de
ses ventes pour l'habitat des
particuliers ils peuvent y installer un
salon et profiter de la chaleur ambiante
c'est vrai que la tendance les gens
recherchent un produit joli de bonne
qualité des choses qui avec style
verrière avec des petits carreaux des
soubassements avec des coloris un petit
peu tendance pastel selon une étude de
l'Ifop 2022 cette Français sur dix
possède un jardin et 72% d'entre eux
prennent plaisir à l'entretenir